welcome to saw's talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sasnik
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's special episode
we're going to be breaking down
the 2020 presidential election
trump versus biden and who you should be
voting for
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
so the 2020 election is less than a week
away we are in the home stretch we just
wrapped up the final presidential debate
and it is going
down to the wire so on today's episode
we're gonna break down a few different
things
the facts we're just gonna give you the
facts right down the middle
no bias whatsoever we're going to give
you the tail of the tape
biden versus trump and then last but not
least why you should vote
why you should vote so just real quick
if you've ever seen me
on the bet david podcast shout out to
patrickbetdavid on the podcast that we
do
you might know that i lean one way or
another and there's some people that
think that i'm a little
too much of this or a little too much of
that so here's what i have i have my
friend sam over here
my friend sam loves trump he's got a
maga hat going on he's cheering for
trump in the background
out of my friend nancy over here she
loves obama she loves biden she's got a
blue hat going on over there
and she's making sure that i'm not
making fun of joe biden so there's no
partisanship
i'm giving you the facts right down the
middle no soy boy stuff no maga stuff
no nothing straight down the middle at
the end of this episode
i want you to tell me how i did if i was
fair
and balanced for both sides so with that
being said there are no opinions here
only the facts and let's jump right in
to the facts boom facts so let's start
with 2016. let's take it take it take it
back to 2016.
some people cried in 2016. some people
cheered in 2016 but we're going to break
down
the numbers in this pie chart right here
well what happened in 2016
65.8 million people that was 28
of the population of the eligible voters
voted
for hillary clinton she did not win as
you know 26.8 percent
which is 62.9 million voted for trump
as you know he won the electoral college
beat hillary clinton so that's what
happened in 2016
but there's one little stat that i want
to show you 41.7 percent almost 42
percent
which is almost 109 million americans
who are eligible to vote did not
vote so the largest part of the
electorate did not vote so this is the
part of the america
who better start to give a [ __ ] you can
see that
in the graph right here so these are all
facts these are according to the
washington post and the census bureau
that's where we got these numbers if you
have an issue with these numbers talk to
them now moving right along let's talk
about
why biden supporters support joe biden
and why trump supporters support donald
trump let's get right into
the support factor so each on this list
right here we talk about different
topics
and then biden and trump and what their
supporters have to say about them and
what grade
they give their candidate in each of
these categories so let's go down the
list by the way this is according to the
pew research center so i know a lot of
people get triggered when you say
certain things
you know politically but this is
according to pew so that's where i took
it from there so the first topic is
energy who is more energetic
according to biden supporters they gave
biden a score of 64
out of 100 trump supporters gave him a
93 out of 100
so clearly trump supporters believe
trump is more
energetic next up we got courageousness
who is more courageous biden supporters
gave biden a score of 75
trump supporters gave trump a score of
91 so trump scores very high
in energy and courage okay next topic
who cares more about ordinary people
they both scored pretty high on this
category
biden 84 trump edged them out though at
89.
who is more honest who's more honest
according to
biden supporters biden got a score of
80.
according to trump supporters he got a
score of 78 so also
pretty similar so both supporters think
their candidate is pretty
honest here we go who is a good role
model well biden supporters gave joe
biden a 78
trump supporters gave him a 68. so they
think he's full of energy
full of courageousness but not exactly a
great role model okay i can understand
that
who is more even tempered biden
supporters gave joe his highest score
here 84 even tempered
even trump supporters will admit that
trump doesn't have
the best temper they gave him a 53 these
are just the facts
according to biden supporters and trump
supporters
and the pew research center so all in
all we got trump very energetic
courageous cares about his people pretty
damn honest where we got
joe biden cares about ordinary people
he's a good role model and he's even
tempered so that's the tale of the tape
when it comes to that now who does vegas
like
to win the election let's talk about
odds so if you've ever bet before if you
ever bet in vegas they give you lines
they give you odds if you've ever bet
with bookies
it's all about the lines that odds so
here we go who is favored in vegas
well according to las vegas joe biden
is the favorite let me break down the
numbers biden is minus 150 to as high as
minus
180 whereas trump is plus 125
to as high as plus 160. so what does
that even mean what does that mean that
means if you want to win a hundred
dollars you're gonna bet a hundred
dollars
you need to bet 150 to as much as 180
on joe biden to win a hundred dollars so
you got to bet 150
or up to 180 to win a hundred dollars so
he's the favorite
whereas trump if you bet a hundred
dollars on trump
you could win 125 or as much as 160.
now these odds change every single day
they go up they go down but they've
stayed pretty steady right here
so clearly according to vegas biden is
the favorite
but let me ask you guys now let me ask
you guys now do you see
the same thing happening in 2020 as it
did in 2016 like a remix if you will
when hillary clinton was the favorite
she was expected to win all the polls
had her up
but then trump's not going out at the
end will that happen again in 2016
only time will tell we are less than a
week away what are your thoughts who do
you think is going to win this election
put that in the comments right there
right now it is time for
the tale of the tape let's get right
into it as you can see on the left side
clearly on the left is joe biden and on
the right side clearly on the right
is donald trump the current president
united states you got biden on the left
you got trump on the right why did i put
fight on the left and trump on the right
well you can do the math on that so now
let's go down the list
category by category starting with the
top
at the party we get the democratic party
over here the democratic nominee and the
republican candidate
trump let's talk about age now let's
talk about age
joe biden is currently 77 years old and
you can say there's a little ashjic
right there because if he should
win the election by the time he is sworn
in he will have reached his 78th
birthday
that will make him the oldest president
ever now who was the oldest president
elected ever before potentially joe
biden well it was donald trump
donald trump is currently 74 years old
but when he was sworn in in 2016
he was 70 years old that was the oldest
president
ever sworn in next up you know we're all
about the money here this is
valuetainment economic sales talks money
where all we talk is money we're going
to address the money we're going to talk
about
money raised now this is according to
npr
money tracker here we go joe biden and
the dnc joe biden in the dnc
raised a total of 1.35 billion dollars
1.35 billion dollars they've spent a
little
under 1.1 billion dollars
they still have cash on hand 275 million
and here's the kicker they've cranked it
up during september
they've raised 358 million in the month
of september alone
where does that compare to trump well
trump outraised biden
trump raised almost 1.5 billion dollars
he spent the majority of it though
1.38 billion cash on hand he has 148
million and in september
he raised 153 million compare that to
biden's 358. so both these guys have
raised
over a billion dollars and have spent
over a billion dollars that's money on
money on money
to win the presidential election what do
you think about
all this money coming in to the election
what are your thoughts so moving right
along let's talk about taxes now all
this information about to share with you
right now
comes from the biden and trump websites
directly from the websites
and a report that was put together by j
p morgan so again if you've got issues
you go right to the source
not to me this is all facts no opinions
now let's talk about taxes
trump wants to maintain and extend the
tax cuts this would lower corporate and
individual taxes
but this could cost the government 1.5
trillion dollars that's
between 20 and 25. so trump he wants to
maintain and extend
the 2017 tax cuts what did those tax
cuts do
they lowered corporate and individual
taxes for high earners
now what's the downside of that
according to the committee for a
balanced federal budget
this could cost the government 1.5
trillion
in the next five to 10 years now what
does joe biden want to do
joe biden wants to increase taxes on
corporate income
on high earners and on capital gains tax
aka he wants to tax
the one percent he's expected to raise
four trillion dollars over the next
decade
let me give you some bottom line when it
comes to taxes because i know this is a
big big issue
when it comes to trump overall he's
somewhere between 20
and 37 percent 20 and 37 when it comes
to biden he's somewhere between
28 and as high as 52 so there's no
denying that taxes
will go up under the democrat joe biden
so that's the tax issue
moving right along let's talk about
regulation well trump wants to reduce
regulation on energy and financial
services
whereas joe biden wants to heighten
regulation
on energy tech and financial services so
that's the regulation
component moving along let's talk about
the environment and climate change
environment and climate change what does
trump want to do he wants to increase
energy production he obviously withdrew
from the paris climate agreement
and he rolled back obama's clean power
plan and trump
has said on many times he calls climate
change a hoax what are your thoughts on
that
then you got biden now what does biden
want to do biden wants to
reduce emissions and increase energy
efficiency
he wants to rejoin the paris climate
agreement
and also he has a two trillion dollar
plan to combat climate change
and invest in clean energy so that's the
difference when it comes to the
environment
and climate change what are your
thoughts on that i know that's a huge
issue
for gen z vote so now let's talk about
foreign policy what does trump want to
do
trump is all about america first as you
know america first america first
and one of his methodologies is called
unilateralism unilateralism if you're
not familiar with that word that
basically means
when the u.s acts alone in our own
best interest that's something that
trump has been a proponent of
unilateralism now what does biden want
to do biden wants a renewed emphasis
on alliances and multilateralism now
what is multilateralism you may ask
multilateral is it a systematic use of
international institutions
that promote u.s interests so on one
hand you got trump
america first unilateralism america
alone and on one hand you got
biden renewed emphasis on alliances and
working together with our allies
one way or another it's going to get the
job done moving right along now let's
talk about health care health care is a
big
subject of debate now when it comes to
health care obviously trump has been
saying for years he wants to repeal
and replace obamacare repeal and replace
he wants to undo the affordable care act
now what does
baiden want to do biden obviously wants
to protect the affordable care act
because he helped build it
with obama so he would build on the aca
which is obamacare the affordable
care act and add a medicare like public
option we've heard about this public
option before so what are your thoughts
on health care
now here we have something where they
actually agree upon when it comes to
health care
both want to reduce the price of
prescription drugs
i think that's something we can all
agree with save that money on
prescription drugs
cool let's talk about labor let's talk
about labor let's talk about labor
money money money money talk about labor
trump has no change
does not want to increase the minimum
wage whereas joe biden
wants to raise the wage to a quote
unquote
livable wage 15 an hour he also wants to
regulate
the gig economy for the gig economy
workers out there so that's your take
on labor now let's talk about
immigration now trump obviously is
tougher
on immigration he wants a tougher border
enforcement and he wants to
build that wall biden on the other hand
what does he have biden has an
immigration reform plan
that includes a pathway to citizenship
for undocumented
immigrants and he also wants to invest
in the latin american countries
to do what to reduce violence and
poverty in their country
so those are the different takes on
immigration what are your thoughts on
immigration i'd love to hear in the
comments below
moving right along we actually have
something that they both agree upon can
you believe it the candidates agree upon
something
and what do they agree upon they agree
upon infrastructure
you see in purple here when they purple
they agree purple agree that's red and
blue come together
purple we want more of that so trump
favors a big
infrastructure spending plan yeah he
wants to do a two trillion dollar
what he calls very big and bold
plan there's that now biden also favors
a big
infrastructure spending plan and he put
together a 10-year plan that will cost
1.3 trillion dollars that will focus on
clean energy jobs
for the middle class so it's good to see
that both these candidates agree upon
something what do they agree upon
big infrastructure spending rebuilding
our roads
rebuilding our bridges rebuilding
america i think that's something we
could all
agree with don't you think all right
then we got housing where do these
candidates
differ on housing now here's what trump
wants to do trump is looking to end
fannie mae and freddie mac fannie mae
and freddie mac he's looking to end that
why because they control
50 percent of u.s mortgages and what
does trump want to do
trump wants more competition for private
companies that's pretty cool
more competition for private companies
get the government out of housing
now what does baiden want to do biden
plans to end
redlining he plans to end housing
discrimination
and he wants more affordable housing so
i think both of these candidates kind of
got a plan
on housing maybe they can come together
and figure something out both seem
pretty reasonable on that so now let's
talk about college loans what does trump
want to do when it comes to college well
trump
wants to end subsidized student loans
and wants to end the public service loan
forgiveness program very interesting now
what does joe biden want to do when it
comes to college
joe biden is actually proposing a
four-year public college
for free for families that are making
under 125 000
dollars a year that's something i know
bernie has been an advocate of
now biden seems to be hitching his wagon
onto that what are your thoughts on that
free four year college for families
making 100 under 125 000.
he also has a 100 loan forgiveness
program
which is a 20-year payment plan for
responsible
borrowers that's interesting so that's
where they differ on student loans and
going to college interesting love to get
your comments
on that my college students love to hear
your opinion on that next up we got
china let's talk about china what's
going on with this china policy well
trump
clearly tough on china they've been in
the middle of a trade war
between china sometimes we're winning
sometimes we're losing i don't know your
thoughts on the trade war and how it's
going but
trump is certainly tough on china now
according to this report
fighting is also tough on china or plans
to beat chaff on china
he has said he wants a firm approach on
china what are your thoughts on that do
you think trump is tougher on china
do you think biden can actually match
how tough it's being on china
big debate i know a lot of people think
that china is our number one threat
which i agree with so let's see where we
go on that and last but not least
you can see it on the bottom what's
going on here with the federal budget
and the federal debt well i have bad
news because
both both candidates are running up big
deficits
they're not balancing the budget and
they are both not
saving that money it's spent spent spend
the deficit and the debt is going higher
and at some point
this [ __ ] needs to get figured out but
we'll see what happens with that
that my friends is the tale of the tape
ding ding ding what do
you think so moving right along let's
wrap this up you might be saying
saz what's your point what's your point
if you've ever seen the bet david
podcast he's always saying
what's your point what's your point so
what's my point you ask well my point is
this
your ass needs to vote we started this
conversation with the fact that in 2016
almost 109
million americans who are eligible to
vote did not vote
so can i make it a suggestion here's my
suggestion can you get your ass to the
polls
and vote now i don't care if you vote
left
i don't care if you vote right i don't
care if you vote biden i don't care if
you vote trump
just vote this time around there is no
viable
third party candidate in 2016. i forgot
to mention it three percent of the
electorate voted for
a third party there's no one on the
third party ticket this year
that's actually has a chance of winning
so make sure you vote for neither
democrat or republican no third party
candidates this time around
get your ass to the polls and vote now
you might be saying well why should i
vote
my vote doesn't affect anything my vote
doesn't matter well it does because i
just went through this entire list
are you telling me on this entire list
there's not anything you care about
you don't care about taxes you don't
care about climate change you don't care
about immigration you don't care about
housing
you don't care about what's going on
with china there has to be something on
this list that you identify with
and there has to be something worthy of
your vote so get your ass to the polls
because your
vote matters that's why you should vote
because things
matter to you now who am i talking about
when it comes to voting you know i'm
looking right at you and i'm looking you
right in the eye
to my swing state voters there's certain
states that control the entire
freaking election i'm not talking about
california i'm not talking about new
york
i'm not talking about oklahoma i'm not
talking about west virginia we know
where those states are voting
but they're swing state voters that the
entire country is depending on now what
are those states
let's go down the list we got michigan
we got minnesota we got wisconsin we got
ohio the entire freaking midwest
we got iowa georgia north carolina
nevada arizona pennsylvania and my home
state of florida
get your ass to the polls and vote pick
a candidate and go with them
and vote the election the election is
tuesday
november 3rd let me say that again the
election is tuesday november 3rd it's
always the first tuesday in november
in case you didn't know tuesday november
3rd get your ass to the polls and vote
now again i don't care if you vote left
i don't care if you vote right i don't
care if you vote blue
i don't care if you vote red i don't
care if you vote biden i don't care if
you vote trump
get your ass to the polls and vote why
because america where the red white and
the blue
they're all on the same team we are all
on the same boat and here's actually one
of my
favorite quotes we are two wings of the
same bird just let me show you that
image and let that sink in for a second
a bird can't fly if only one wing is
dominating okay no birds just flapping
around like this
takes two wings for that bird to fly
that is a great
metaphor for where we are in america
today you have to listen to your fellow
americans
you have to respect your fellow
americans even if they have a different
opinion than you
hear them out hear why they want to vote
this way hear why they believe in this
cause now i'll tell you this no matter
who gets elected
whether it's trump again or whether it's
biden the one thing that you need to
focus on
is yourself and your wealth and make
sure that you
are saving that money because the
government will not be there to help
you you need to help yourself with that
being said that's the end of this
episode i'd love to hear
who you're voting for in the comment
section with that being said there are
two videos i would love for you to watch
number one
the heroes act versus the heels act
which talks about
stimulus checks and unemployment and
everything that's going on in congress
right now
and number two the interview i did with
daryl davis who convinces kkk members
to leave the clan so that's it that's
the end of this episode if you have not
already subscribed
to valuetainment economics do so below
and give that like button a little smash
if you would and if we've learned
anything from this episode
the government will not bail you out you
need to focus on
yourself your wealth and save
that money all we talk is money
all we talk we talk is money